I haven't purchased in a particular way
because I looked at the question and I
saw that it didn't just want positive
definite it actually wanted positive
definite and in a second it's gonna ask
me to work out negative definite as well
so you can see I have taken this part
first because the discriminant will just
tell me whether it's definite definite
I've worked that out and then I'm going
to take two different inequalities for a
and that'll tell me concave up or
concave down okay so let's walk through
here's my quadratic dividing through by
four is fine because four is positive so
my inequality stays that way
there's my factorized form I have a look
at my graph it's concave up so I want
the part between which is what we
anticipated before so to 218
non-inclusive okay we're so far okay
with that so now my graph will be
definitely okay for positive definite I
come back to this condition on the
leading coefficient on a right and I go
through now once I march through this is
what I have at the end now I've crunched
all the numbers and you need to think
what do you conclude out of this how do
i satisfy remember I want the
intersection of both of these
inequalities well you can clean who's
got an answer okay this is interesting
right
what in two thirds right one or two
thirds is below two right that's that's
precisely why I put it is a big steamer
all right so being that this includes
the entirety of this right so if I draw
this on a number limit here's my number
line kind of one in two thirds
there should be hollow circles sorry one
or two thirds is here right and then it
goes all the way this way okay if I want
the intersection between this little
part and this bigger part all that means
is it's just a little part that's all
okay so I have yes so in other words
this pit opposes me no problems if I
mean here then this is always satisfied
great so now when I move into Part B
which is for negative definite
because we already did the legwork to
work out what happens for a positive
I've already worked out what happens for
kami right
it's just the opposite of this do you
see that I mean I could reverse this if
you like 3k minus five is less than zero
but you can see I'm going to go through
exactly the same steps here to simplify
out make K the subject the only
difference is doctor thought that the
inequality is facing the other direction
okay now again you've crushed your
numbers but now it's up to you to take
all of that and draw a conclusion what
that is okay make this quadratic
negative definite aha I'm a problem
don't I
let's come back to this I'm gonna clean
it up a little bit just so you can see
it as a number line see it really
clearly this guy in here is 2 to 18
there is okay this is less than and we
already demonstrated one or two thirds
is below two so I'm going this way I
want to be intersection the place where
these inequalities overlap and then
never ever half right so therefore I
could say no real values okay now what's
really interesting with this is that
like we would have thought okay I can
change K to be anything I like so I
should be able make this quadratic
anything I like well no because there's
a relationship here right I'm love you
go to go to des Vosges plug this here
right once you put this in it'll say if
you liked you add a slide up for K right
you go ahead you do it right and then as
you vary K because you know what values
are happening here you might need to
change the domain okay I think the
default is negative terms of ten so do
something where I should go past 18 see
what happens you should be able to
anticipate what you think will happen
float around you'll never be able to
find a value K no matter how far you go
that will give you a graph that looks
like this right according to what we
have concluded it just can't be done
just as a bit of an int good right
pottsy says I don't want the contract to
be definite I want it to be indefinite
and we have in a sense already worked
out the answer to this question right
what if I wanted to be indefinite where
do I go in this working to look at what
will give me the inequality first yeah
okay so if this is what makes it
definite then if I don't have this it
will be indefinite right so it's this is
an inside right so I want the outsides
right so I want K to be less than or
equal to 2 I don't have the boundary
here so it has to be heat or okay is
greater than or equal to 18 that's just
the outsides tada it's indefinitely
right for either no that's right now
there's one more thing I'm missing there
so one thing I'd miss you
let's just look at what this looks like
on this number line okay so we look like
this okay you're right with that that's
where it is but I've already identified
for you a problem there's one tiny tiny
little problem with this domain that
I've stated right it's all ok over here
I'll give you that clear there's
something wrong over here that you have
to watch out for right for it to be a
quadratic
that's indefinite for it to be a
quadratic
that's indefinite it needs to be a
quadratic doesn't it does that make
sense because if it's not a quadratic
I'm gonna be indignant quadratic now
what condition would make this guy go on
a quadratic answer yeah when this guy
zero right I already know when this is
zero it's this point here see that
that's the point at which K is equal to
sorry where a is equal to zero right so
that can't be part of the inequality
that's really sneaky isn't it right
you're just concentrating on this but
there's one tiny little value that stops
at being not only limited by the
quadratic altogether
so this or this but
cannot equal 5 over 3
okay that's the one 2/3 that's the value
which makes it not indefinitely it makes
it not quadratic so you can't have that